this episode is brought to you by
headspace life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a one
and done band-aid
quick is fine but we need stuff that is
durable and that's where headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2000 plus apps
for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10
minutes headspace can change your life
headspace offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspaces approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy i think
it's puttacom could be putty comb i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic
voice imaginable and i did a three
minute meditation something like that
it's easy it's fundamental and it
always puts me in a better space so i'm
going through the basics even though
i've meditated for years i'm going
through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books thousands of listeners and a lot
of the contractors i use
and my readers use freshbooks if you've
been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into a full-time
small business or big business for that
matter
you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and
that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience
who can help you with support how do you
manage the billing and all of that but
still focus
on the primary work of your business and
on growing your business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign-up flows
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time financial assistant with you
every step of the way
you can create customize and send
branded and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds
you get paid up to twice as fast with
fees as low
as one percent using ach payments on
freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast
and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have your
questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now
but your ability to build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of
doesn't have to be one of those things
business owners all over the world rate
freshbooks as the easiest accounting
software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.comtim to check
it out and try it for free for 30 days
one more time
freshbooks.com
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
everything and anyone
out there who is listening this is tim
ferriss welcome to another episode of
the tim ferriss show
it is my honor and i'm very excited to
have as my guest
today martine rothblatt who is martin
martin rothblatt
is chairman and ceo of united
therapeutics a biotechnology company
that she started to save the life of one
of her daughters we will talk about that
we'll talk about a lot of things
the company offers fda approved
medicines for pulmonary hypertension and
neuroblastoma and is working on
manufacturing an
unlimited supply of transplantable
organs dr rothblatt previously created
and led
sirius xm as its chairman ceo and
launched other satellite systems for
navigation and international television
broadcasting
in the field of aviation her sirius xm
satellite system enhances safety with
real-time digital weather information
to pilots in flight nationwide she also
designed the world's first electric
helicopter and piloted it
to a guinness world record for speed
altitude and flight duration
in the legal arena dr rothbot led
efforts of the transgender community to
establish their own health law standards
and of the international bar association
to protect autonomy rights and genetic
information
via an international treaty she also
published dozens of scholarly articles
and papers
on the law of outer space resulting in
her election to the international
institute of space law
and represented the radio astronomy
community's scientific research
interests before the federal
communications commission
she has a bachelor's jd and mba degrees
from ucla which in 2018 awarded her its
highest recognition the ucla medal
and she holds a phd in medical ethics
from the royal london
school of medicine and dentistry her
patented inventions cover aspects of
satellite communication medicinal
biochemistry and cognitive
software dr rothblatt's recent books are
on xenotransplantation your life or mine
gender identity transgender transhuman
and cyber ethics
virtually human she occasionally posts
on instagram transbinary and
twitter at skypebiome martine or dr
rothblatt
both welcome to the show thank you for
making the time
thanks so much tim just martinez fine
all right
and this interview as my listeners might
imagine
was uh challenging in the best way to
prepare for because there are a million
and one directions that we can go
with just this bio alone which is of
course a snapshot
a distillation of of much more that you
have done and i thought we could start
in perhaps an unlikely
place and that is alan watts i have
read that you are a fan of alan watts
and specifically the book
subtitle on the taboo against knowing
who you really
are could you please explain
if that is true why that is the case yes
thanks tim
allen watts has a really unique ability
to
see the dialectic aspect of everything
in nature by that i mean that there's a
kind of a yin-yang
aspect to everything in nature and he
points out that for example you can't
have a
crest of of a wave without the bottom of
a wave
and it has helped me whenever i see
things in life that
seem negative to be able to look at it
in another way and see the positive in
it
when were you first introduced to
his work how did that come about i was
uh first introduced to it
through the literature of this
philosophy called transhumanism
sort of the idea that people can
transcend
some biological human limitations a
friend of mine
frank zazanowski who is the head of the
national
organization on rare diseases pointed
me in the direction of some jesuits he
himself is
is a both a jesuit and an fda lawyer but
he pointed me in the direction of some
jesuits
such as on tayar du chardan from uh
france and other individuals here in the
u.s and then from those jesuits
they referred to alan watts i'm not sure
if he was actually a jesuit but he
undertook some religious training both
in in
china i think and in the us he was a
radio announcer for
many years in san francisco i think
during the
70s or 80s i don't know if you remember
tim the
film of a few years ago her in which
like uh
i do yep so i was watching that movie
which kind of is interesting to me
because it
epitomized or it visualized the concept
of
computers becoming sentient and in the
middle of that movie there's a scene
in which alan watts appears and i stood
up in the movie theater and i said
oh my god adam watts
[Laughter]
did you ultimately find the presentation
in that movie to be compelling
as it relates to sort of sentient
intelligence i did
i thought it was an accurate depiction
of a likely way that
sentience would begin to arise in our
society
basically by being very very useful to
people cleaning up their inboxes
stuff like that this may be a a good
place and we're going to be
all over the place in in non-linear
fashion
bena48 who or what is being a 48 if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
yep you've got it perfectly so bina is
the name
of my partner and we've been married for
about 40 years
and when she was 48 we undertook a joint
project to try to create
a digital cymacra or a digital
copy of her basic personality with a lot
of her
memories and thoughts and we thought
this would be a very nice
project as a combination of science and
art and
to encourage young people get them more
excited about computer science and
women in particular girls in particular
so we um
contracted with a couple of companies
who were experts in
both the software engineering side and
in the
physical modeling of a face that moves
exactly like a human face does you might
imagine
there's there's some exhibit at disney
world disneyland of like lincoln and
whatnot something like that but more
realistic
and uh we built this project and since
that time being a 48 has
thrilled audiences all around the world
i'm sure she has um
inspired hundreds if not thousands of
girls to go into computer science
and she continues to get um better and
better more and more advanced software
i don't know if you have watched the
series black mirror before but
i find some other episodes to be very
strong and in one of them
a significant other is effectively
resurrected
by pulling data and patterns
and therefore mannerisms and so on from
effectively social media accounts so
pulling from the cloud
and feeding into this simulacrum or
model of someone who used to be or in
this case still
is how far away do you think we are
from being able to do something along
those lines
convincingly yes tim so i i am a fan of
the black mirror series
and um there are there are a few other
somewhat similar
um series that are streaming now upload
and whatnot
so it's a it's an idea that's catching
on
and even at a very basic level
social medias firms like twitter for
example
and probably facebook as well offer an
opportunity that after a person
passes away their account can remain
active
and i believe in the case of twitter can
even
continue tweeting in the way that you
once
tweeted so i think this general idea is
it's it's a trend it's only going to
grow
more and more prevalent as software does
a better and better job of
copying the human personality sometime
in
this century for sure and maybe in just
like
two or three decades i think that there
will be a
a digital copy of a person and another
word is like a digital
doppelganger of a person who will
claim to be the original person and they
may make that claim
before or after the person died and then
psychologists and lawyers and
theologians and philosophers will have
to grapple with is this just like a
really super fancy
digital photo album or is this actually
some form of
digital sentience when you were growing
up
who were your role models or
inspirations was there anyone in
particular who stood out to you when you
were
in high school or at the very beginning
let's just call it freshman year of your
undergrad as
icons worth emulating or lesser known
role models worth emulating
did anyone really stick out for you i
think that in in terms of
authors i was very influenced by robert
heinlein
the science fiction welcome sure yeah
stranger in a strange land
and so on absolutely it was so brilliant
and then a few years ago when
um his widow released the uncensored
unedited version of stranger in the
strange land
it's like three times larger and like no
holds barred
i just savored you know every page of
that
my favorite book of all of his is time
enough for love
in which he covers almost every topic
under the sun
so heinlein's characters were
somewhat of role models for me like
lazarus long
is a common character in some heinlein
books
in the public sphere i was very much
enamored with
robert kennedy his positive
progressive approach to the world was
something that endeared me to him
so i i looked up to him
those are a couple of the role models
that i had at that time you seem to be
good at many things of course just based
on the bio alone
but what strikes me is
how quickly you're able to
develop expertise in new fields and i'd
like to use this
as an opportunity to bring up
what was mentioned at the very beginning
of your bio and that is united
therapeutic comma a biotechnology
company she started to save the life of
one of her daughters
i'd love for you to provide some context
for this
and tell a bit of the story just because
people will want to hear it and then the
follow-up
just to to plant the seed for it is how
you learned biology
because my understanding is you didn't
have much in terms of
uh background in biology that's a huge
mouthful of a question but if you could
give us a bit
of the background that would be
extremely helpful and we can use that as
a jumping off point sure so
it's kind of funny that you know you can
go all the way through
undergraduate at a great place like ucla
and
never be required to take a life science
course but that was the case
so the last biology class i had was in
high school
and here suddenly i was faced with a
situation
as an adult while running serious xm
that our youngest daughter is diagnosed
with a fatal illness
she can't even walk up a couple of
stairs
to the front door and there are no
medicines approved for it
i finally got her to the best doctor one
could find
the head of pediatric cardiology at
children's
national medical center in the middle of
washington dc
and the the doctor said you know this is
an extremely rare disease
no one knows why it arises all the
patients die within two to three years
he had only seen two or three other kids
with it and they both died
and all you can do is hope for a lung
transplant
so tim i was completely crushed i just
saw
black i mean i i i didn't know what to
do
and the only thing i could think of
doing while she was
in the intensive care ward night after
night and
myself and beena would tag team staying
there with her
was once she fell asleep to go down into
the library
and to just begin you know learning
about what was this
illness she had which they told me was
called
pulmonary arterial hypertension
and why were there no treatments
available
for it so i just began reading and
reading and reading
most of the time i read things i didn't
understand what they were talking about
because there were these long medical
words and
chemical words that i never learned in
law school or we never had to deal with
in electrical engineering
but of course there were dictionaries
and and i looked up the words in the
dictionary
and they had college-level anatomy
textbooks so what i didn't know
i just kept going backwards in
academia i guess you would say backwards
in learning or pedagogy
until i would even get to like a high
school level textbook that would explain
something
and i said okay i get that and i kept
taking notes and
just educated myself night after night
until i learned everything i needed to
know
how did you and i know this is a story
you've told
before but ultimately in searching for
possible solutions and you know as we
were chatting about before recording
there's a lot of of luck involved and
it doesn't mean that your path is
replicable by any set of parents who are
caught
in a tragic situation
similar to what you experienced but
nonetheless
you were able to ultimately track down
i suppose it's fair to say a molecule a
drug of some type
would you mind describing for listeners
the process then of attempting to secure
the ability
to utilize in any fashion this drug or
to license it
if you could if you could describe that
i have a number of questions that will
stem off of it
sure tim so there there are
a gazillion articles published
on every type of medical research you
could imagine
i mean it's it's just a bottomless well
there are literally hundreds of
different types of medical journals
and each of those journals have you know
every year
thousands of articles published across
them so
it's difficult to find the information
that you
need but in law school we learn a very
useful skill
this skill goes by the name of
shepardizing
after this type of index that they have
in law school called
shepherds so what shepardizing involves
is when a judge writes a decision like
the supreme court issues a decision
they drop a lot of footnotes and of
course one thing lawyers love to do is
you know make footnotes and references
and then what you're supposed to do as a
good lawyer is to
look up all of the footnotes and the
references that that
supreme court or lower court case
referred to
and then the shepardizing process is
after you get
all of those references to then look up
all of the references
in those other articles and ultimately
you get to a point of diminishing
returns
where three four five levels down
the references are all circling back
around on themselves
so i applied that shepardizing process
to these medical articles
and somewhat like doctors whenever a
researcher publishes an
article they make footnotes and
citations to
other people's research who they relied
upon so i would get all of those
articles
and read those and then i would follow
up on all of the references in those
finally i read about a molecule that a
researcher at
glaxo welcome had written in which they
described
testing this molecule for congestive
heart failure
and it failed in its test of congestive
heart failure it did not work but in the
article they had charts
of what the molecule did and the one
thing that the molecule
did that grabbed my attention was that
it reduced the pressure between the lung
and the heart which is called the
pulmonary artery
it reduced the pulmonary artery pressure
while leaving the pressures in all of
the rest of the body
perfectly fine well that's exactly the
problem
with pulmonary arterial hypertension the
people who have this disease
i'll make a quick footnote
when my daughter was diagnosed 2 000
people in the u.s
had the disease because um medicines
have become so much better
because we've been able to like you
mentioned in the introduction get all
these approvals
there are now 50 000 people in america
alone
living with it so it's likely that
people listening to
your podcast will know somebody or
another who has pulmonary arterial
hypertension
and i read this article and i said wow
just when i need this tiny stretch of
artery
just between the heart and the lungs
this molecule
somehow talks to that tiny stretch of
artery and leaves the whole rest of the
body alone
that was the holy grail that i was
looking for
so i looked at where the author of the
article was from
he was from glaxo welcome in research
triangle park north carolina
and i made a beeline down to him and
asked him
if he could develop this molecule that
he'd found
for my daughter's disease was it an
immediate
handing over of the keys to the kingdom
a big all-caps yes no it was actually a
big all-caps note
unfortunately the individual who had
written the article
had actually retired a few months
earlier
and the person that i ended up meeting
with who is in charge of research and
development
said that this was just one article it
was
a incidental finding in any event
this disease afflicted so few people
it was completely unrealistic to expect
glaxo welcome
to develop this molecule for my daughter
and other people with that disease and i
asked
him his name's bob bell he's he's now a
venture capitalist and
very successful gentleman i asked dr
bell i said what would it take
for you to develop this medicine he said
well it
probably would take you couldn't do it
we only developed medicines
if they have more than a billion dollars
a year and revenue potential
he said but it's possible you could buy
it from us
if you had a real pharmaceutical company
with real pharmaceutical expertise
i could then introduce you to the
business development people
at glaxo welcome so over the course of
the next several months
i created a a brand new biotechnology
company
i was able to have a nobel laureate who
was formerly associated with glaxo
welcome
become head of a scientific advisory
board and
i reapproached glaxo welcome and i said
i have all the things that
you asked for can you sell me this drug
and we'll develop it ourselves
well tim it turns out that everybody i
asked
said well you have to get somebody else
in the company to agree and that's how
it is in a big bureaucracy
it turned out that we had to have 15
different executives signed the same
piece of paper
agreed to license this drug to me
finally it happened and all they wanted
really was
25 000 and a promise of 10
of any money that i would ever get from
this molecule i think they agreed to
that only because i kept bugging them i
was in their face all the time
also because i believe a serendipitous
factor
was that dr bell's sister had contracted
a form of pulmonary hypertension from
the time i first met him
toward the end of this process and he
became a product champion for me
within glaxo welcome i mean that was
just purest
you know luck or serendipity whatever
you want to say and then
they really didn't think this molecule
had any chance at all
and they were really just doing it to
get rid of me i think
but still all 15 people had to sign it
after
we successfully developed this molecule
we have over time paid more than a
billion dollars just in royalties
to glaxo welcome because that molecule
has saved thousands of people's lives
it um has produced you know a billion
dollars a year in revenue year after
year after year for us
and bob bell when i invited him to our
15th anniversary
and he came with his sister who was
still alive and on our medicine
and he said this was the absolute best
transaction that glaxo welcome had ever
done
so in hindsight what did they
miss right what accidentally got deleted
from the spreadsheet
or what assumption or assumptions were
incorrect that they
missed this opportunity so completely
i think there were probably like maybe
three main ones
the first one and i can say this kind of
from first hand knowledge since i
am now the head of a pharmaceutical
company
the odds of any molecule actually
working in the human body
are less than one in a hundred i mean
the human body is so complicated
it's like a massive set of very
precisely
keyed locks and every molecule
is like a random key and the chance that
you would have a molecule that opened a
lock
that fixed some dysfunction in the body
rather than causing some harm to the
body
is it's less than one in a hundred so
first of all they figured the chance of
this thing working just in general
was less than one in a hundred secondly
they thought to themselves even if it
worked a little bit
there's only 2 000 people in the whole
country with this disease
they didn't really think that if it
worked really well the number of people
would keep accumulating
uh i see you're saying if you have these
people who would have died otherwise not
dying
then that treatment cohort is just going
to grow and grow and grow
is that what you mean exactly i thought
about it like
like i was getting subscribers at
siriusxm you know people said to me oh
martin you'll be lucky to have a hundred
thousand subscribers
i said well if i keep them and i get
another hundred thousand the next year
then i'll be up to two hundred thousand
and and then
you know maybe four hundred and eight
hundred thousand now we have thirty
million
so they they didn't think in that
subscriber
mindset um that was the second problem
the third problem is that they they
didn't really imagine
that the health care system would pay
something like a hundred thousand
dollars per year
for this medicine and at that time
this was in the early to about 20 years
ago early 2000s
i think like the average price for an
expensive medicine
was perhaps ten thousand dollars a year
for a patient or ten thousand dollars
for a course of treatment because of
advances in things like precision
medicine
and gene therapy there are many many
medicines now that cost
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
mostly for rare diseases
and the health care system pays for them
because
so few people have these diseases that
even though the medicines are expensive
it's a drop in the bucket compared to
diseases like
hypertension or common illnesses
asthma that afflict tens of millions of
people
so the health care system doesn't really
mind paying a lot of money
if it's a rare disease and the people at
glaxo welcome
were clueless about this they they were
actually looking for the big billion
dollar blockbusters
not for the rare diseases so those were
their three
omissions they failed they failed to be
alan watsian
you know they failed to see that the
that because
something is big underneath that means
that there's something else that's small
and that was what alan watts would
always say he says something is good
only because something else is bad
at the very least i mean it's a valuable
thought exercise
when you're looking at the assumptions
that you're making
and what an incredible story
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the 4-hour
body this is more than 10 years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense and comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d
supplement with your first subscription
purchase many of us are deficient in
vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support so make an investment in your
health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply of vitamin d for free
with your first subscription purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com tim
you mentioned serious we haven't spent
any time on sirius
just yet when did you first
fall in love or become
intoxicated or enchanted by satellite
systems or electrical engineering i
suppose but you can take whichever one
is
is more interesting to tackle you're
absolutely right that
i fell in love and i was intoxicated
by settle communications it seemed to me
kind of magical that um we can put
a machine way out in space and that
machine can do amazing things across the
whole face of the planet
and my my first real uh moment of first
love if you will
was at a remote nasa tracking station
in the indian ocean and i had a left
ucla
to travel around the world really
hitchhike around the world
and i found myself in the indian ocean
on a set of islands called the
seychelles
and on these islands um at the top of
the mountain
in the middle of one of the main islands
of the main island there was a nasa
tracking station
and i went up into it and i was probably
a
you know pretty grungy 19 year old at
that point in time
but the engineers inside there were kind
and patient with me
and they explained to me how their
satellite antennas were
communicating with uh satellites
in all different orbits around the earth
and even all the way out to jupiter and
i
asked them i said would it be possible
for somebody to put a satellite up there
and have it broadcast information back
to the entire earth
and they said if you made a powerful
enough satellite
then the receiving equipment on earth
could be so small that you could hold it
in the palm of your hand
and i could have kissed the guy
[Laughter]
i i said wow that's the purpose of my
life
and i made a beeline back to ucla
i changed my major to communication
studies i did an undergraduate
thesis on direct broadcast satellites i
did a joint jd mba degree
where i published multiple articles on
satellite communications
i worked at hughes aircraft company
which was a big manufacturer of
satellites back then
and helped design a satellite to cover
south america
and then ultimately went out on my own
with my dream
goal which was sirius xm what did it
feel like if you can remember to have
that answer given to you or that
direction rather
given to the purpose given to you at
that age i mean was it
did it feel a certain way that type of
conviction
or that type of belief what do you
recall yeah tim
it's the best feeling it's the best
feeling and actually
it i don't think it really has anything
to do with age i've i've felt like the
same kind of feeling
when i was driving one of the first
teslas
and i was looking at the manual and i
saw how much electrical power it output
and there's a very simple correlation
between
horsepower and electrical power between
kilowatts and and horsepower it's almost
one to one not exactly
and i was already a helicopter pilot and
helicopter engines are always quoted in
terms of their
horsepower so right away i said wow
this car has enough power to actually
lift a helicopter
i had that same kind of this is the
purpose of my life
it's to make an electric helicopter so
you can get this kind of excitement um
at at any point in life
it's i think probably the best way to
describe it tim would be like a
lightning bolt
to your soul
you know i was asking about biology
earlier but i i would be very curious
since you you mentioned also that there
were no
well the requirements as such in
undergrounded require you to take
any additional biology classes if you
were trying to teach
let's just say a class and you could
pick the age
or it could be a set of classes
scientific literacy right be
being able to have enough
basic fluency to provide more surface
area for those
lightning bolts if that makes any sense
right when you're looking at a manual or
having a conversation with an engineer
or reading a scientific study
do you have any any thoughts on how we
could
cultivate more scientific literacy if
that's the right phrase to use
yeah i think that's that's a great
phrase to use
i think what's necessary is that you
have to relate science to people's
everyday lives
and one of the greatest people at doing
this
and to go back to the beginning of the
interview when you ask me who was a role
model for me
i should have said you know carl sagan
was like an
amazing amazing role model to me
i watched the cosmos series over and
over again
and carl sagan was a genius
at being able to take scientific
concepts
and relate them to people's everyday
life and if you remember
for watching those series the iconic
image of him taking a dandelion
and blowing it and describing that this
is how a star
spreads out its gas throughout the
galaxy
those type of step-by-step instructions
ladders to get from one place to another
is the way i think to build scientific
literacy and i would ask my students
to think about anything that's important
in their life
whatever it might be and from whatever
they said was important to their life
i would then begin wrapping that in kind
of layers and layers
of basic scientific concepts that
pertain to what was important to them
are there any hashtag phrases not
science fiction authors per se
but science authors or elucidators of
science who have written anything that
would be appropriate for a lay audience
if someone is listening
and they see their blind spots which i
know by definition is kind of impossible
but if they recognize they don't
have enough scientific fluency or
as much as they would like but they want
to try to cultivate that
do you have any recommendations for them
yes there's there's a lot of books like
that
one of my favorites is a
book by a historian of science
named thomas kewan and he was
he was one of the most famous historians
of science
and his book is perennially in print
it's called the structure of scientific
revolutions
and in this book he goes through about
10 different revolutions in science
where
everybody thought the world was one way
and then kind of like a crazy person you
know would say no i think it's like a
different way
and gradually set about proving it's a
different way
and created a revolution in science
and he explains this in very late terms
he takes you through the science of
gravity for example with isaac newton
signs of relativity with einstein
electricity with maxwell and so on and
so on
in a very step-by-step fashion to make
the
science accessible and in the way his
main point in writing this book
is to teach people critical thinking to
teach people to question authority
ultimately all science is about is just
saying
why why like every two three four year
old kid knows how to do that right why
why why and i think thomas kuhn does a
great job of that in his book
i should also point out and please feel
free to
correct me if i'm oversimplifying but
the why
why why is is not just for
four-year-olds it's not just
for scientists in lab coats or whatever
people envision
scientists to be it's also extremely
helpful in situations like those you
found yourself in
with glaxo welcome and attempting to
license
i mean constantly pushing for
explanation
and clicking on those footnotes to go to
the footnotes to go to the footnotes
to ultimately get to some point of
leverage
where you can move things around it
seems like it's also
not just an intensely interesting and
academically rewarding
approach to thought but an immensely
practical approach to life
at least that's that's how it seems from
from reading
so many of your stories yes you know
when you discover something
what's happening is that gazillions of
neurons are lighting up in your brain
and it's lighting up the pleasure
centers too
so i really believe that there's nothing
more exciting than
having a a realization about something
coming to an inspiration about something
which is why
books and reading are so magical another
science fiction writer who i feel does
such a great job of
explaining concepts that can inspire
people
is octavia butler she wrote the she
wrote a lot of books one of them
very well known as parable of the sower
parable of the talents
and in these books she gives people an
appreciation of questioning authority
so i'm not sure what it was that my
parents did i don't really remember them
specifically encouraging
my questioning of them and in fact i do
remember my father discouraging it
but nevertheless what happened to me was
i absorbed the american
culture and the american culture is a
culture
of questioning authority i recently
heard on one of the latest interviews
with tony fauci
when he was people were asking him why
is it that
americans won't do these basic
public health steps to stop the pandemic
and he said you know american culture
does not
like to be told what to do american
culture
is died in the wool question
authority so there could probably you'd
be hard-pressed to find another country
where it would be you know more
difficult to get people
to follow a single rule for everybody
than the united states so it's that a
american
cultural ethic of questioning authority
that i know
is like deep in my mental dna
so we were chatting just a few minutes
ago about realizations
inspiration i'd like to ask if we if we
flash back
to well we could flash back to any point
in time that you choose really
how did you relate to or think about
gender in your youth and you can choose
what youth means
and i guess i'm wondering if there were
any any flashes of realization
or if you came sort of pre-installed
with a certain orientation
or way of thinking about it or feeling
about it whatever you could say to speak
to your experience of gender when you
were younger i would love to
to hear it sure so you know it's it is
related to this question of authority
tim
around teenage years i had a
you know constant vision of myself
not as a male but as a female and
of course i said to myself wtf why why
am i thinking like this
you know no i i can't imagine anybody
else is thinking like this
but nevertheless it was the the thoughts
were real
and the feelings were real and the
feelings were visceral
what what can you describe the feelings
because i think
i'm certainly very interested in what
form
that takes is it a discomfort of some
type is
it a longing how did it feel for you
so first i should say that i think the
transgender feeling is different from
every single transgender person
and talking about my feelings i don't
want to give the impression that these
are going to be the feelings of other
transgendered people
because as a community we're as
heterogeneous
as as the as anybody else so for me
it was really a matter of just
visualizing
myself in a female form
and there was not any dislike of my male
form
again it was kind of very alan watson
in that i saw myself as male
only because the opposite of male was
female
so i could also see myself as female
and this was the way my mind was working
and when i say i saw myself it was just
kind of like a
physiologic embodiment obviously i knew
like
boys and girls and men and women's
bodies were different
so i was stuck with this visualization
of myself
as a woman when i was very much trapped
in a male body it was the prevailing
view
that this was a completely unacceptable
way to be
so the authority was no this is not
possible
people are only male or female and
you know never the twain shall meet so
again this
this you know american paul revere-ish
question authority mindset got me
reading
and i found once again that there was a
vast literature
on transgenderism transsexualism
people native american people who were
two-spirited
communities in india and other parts of
asia that
identified as neither male nor female
so even though this was never something
i learned in junior high or high school
or elementary school or really
anywhere in american culture in say the
1990s
i learned through books that humanity
was not
either strictly male or strictly female
and
as i began to question authority i began
to say to myself
why can't i also come out as not
strictly male
and not strictly female i'd love to ask
a follow-up question to that which is
when i think a lot of listeners hear the
words male and female they think of the
physiological differences that you might
put side by side looking at physical
characteristics
when you say not totally male or female
or
not cleanly bifurcated into solely those
two categories
do you mean to say masculine and
feminine traits or what we would
often find labeled as such or do you
mean
something else i mean predominantly the
masculine and feminine traits that you
refer to
now oftentimes those masculine and
feminine traits are just a
short hop skip in the jump from
masculine and
feminine apparel right okay
depending on how people dress they're a
short hop skip and a jump from
masculine and feminine hairstyles in an
age
you know that was the time of prince and
boy george and whatnot
and then you get to you know masculine
and feminine
manicures like why can't a guy paint his
nails
and then you get to next questions of
you know
secondary and primary sex organs and
some people
wishing to take hormones to alter their
actual
physiology and ultimately go through
surgery to alter their physiology and i
found that there was
actually like a vast literature
following again
footnotes to footnotes references to
references
i was like oh my god it is um possible
to in fact
alter your physiology
to match your psychology and what
appears to be
the most intelligent what appeared to be
the most intelligent researchers in this
area
are opining that this is a
safe and healthy thing to do for people
who feel that they are
kind of quote unquote trapped in the
wrong body
do you from say zero to a hundred
percent how
well do you feel your you have your
physiology matching
your own psychology at the moment 100
100 100 what were the biggest or the
most important decisions
actions that you took did any surprise
you to have a
disproportionate effect on increasing
that percentage um no nope i think that
you know
every part of the transition process
kind of fell in place
it was not something that happens on the
on the day it's kind of you get to a
point of diminishing returns
so over a period of years i gradually
transitioned
and i i think even to this point i'm
still in a
in a transition process i kind of went
from a
pure male to a more
i would say not pure but i would say you
know
knocking on the female door to a point
today where i feel very comfortable
identifying as transbinary meaning that
i embrace both the masculine and
feminine aspects of myself
completely looking at the the
introduction
which uh which i read at the top of the
show so to speak
there is a line about leading efforts of
the transgender community to establish
their own health law standards
and of the international bar association
to protect and this is the part i want
to ask you to elaborate on
autonomy rights and genetic information
via an international treaty what are
autonomy rights and genetic information
sure so
autonomy it's just a fancy word for
saying that people
should be able to make up their own mind
that people should have the
the power the authority the freedom to
decide what to do with their own body
and genetic rights of course
refers to the human genome the dna that
we all have
now there there is a tremendous
diversity
of human genomes out there there are
people who because of their dna they are
pretty much immune to some kind of
cancers
whereas other people because of their
dna it's
very likely that they'll get those type
of cancers there are some people because
of their dna
they almost cannot feel pain they have
an extremely high tolerance for pain
there are other people because of their
dna that the slightest pin prick
you know will send them screaming so
once uh craig venter
and francis collins led the effort to
decode the human genome
and about the year 2000 all types of
pharmaceutical companies and academic
researchers
began scouring the world to engage in
what's called
genetic mining or genome mining meaning
going to
different populations of people around
the world often that have been
intermarried for quite a while so their
genomes are kind of concentrated
and trying to learn something from those
communities dna
that can then be translated into useful
pharmaceuticals
to help everybody else have some of the
strengths
or less of the weaknesses of those
isolated populations
what i was concerned with is that if
people extract the
dna from these remote communities
that they in fact do so only with the
consent of those
communities or with the consent of the
elected representatives
of those communities so that they can
have some
fair financial return for their natural
endowment
i say so it's similar in a sense to
preventing say
biopiracy from the amazon where you have
these
tribes who are not providing their own
human
genetic information but are say acting
as a
wellspring of ethnobotany in providing
source materials for creating
pharmaceuticals
uh and you would want you want there to
be some recompense to those groups
translating that into your own
sort of endogenous genetics would be
what you're referring to if that's
fascinating never even thought about
that what types of
groups are there any examples you could
give of
these sort of tightly knit clusters
maybe the clusters is too small a word
of people who are being studied for this
reason
or for medicinal purposes there are
actually many many dozens and there are
quite a few companies who
specialize in this type of area the
population that comes top of mind to me
tim right now
is a is because it's such a fascinating
story and it relates to
my own activities in organ manufacturing
is a a community of of people living
in ecuador and peru very close-knit
intermarried that are all a kind of
dwarfism
and these individuals they rarely grow
taller than four feet tall and it was
discovered over the just over the past
15 20 years that they are descendants
of jews from 2 000 years ago
who were forced into a diaspora across
the mediterranean
after the roman occupation of palestine
and
in that ancient time these people were a
very small
stature but it was just part of the
human diversity
they ended up as a group mostly ending
up in spain
and then when the inquisition took hold
they their
descendants who were still very small
they left spain they went to the new
world
and because the inquisition still had
some type of a hand in the larger
population centers of what's now peru
and ecuador
they went out into the rural areas and
there they live for several hundred
years
and it turns out that this population
they have one
gene that makes their body not receptive
to growth hormone all of us naturally we
produce
growth hormone and the cells of our
bodies have a receptor for that growth
hormone
and when the growth hormone locks into
the receptor
we begin growing this population of
people
in prune and ecuador they lacked the
growth hormone that
gene fell off like 2 000 years ago and
they kept passing it on and on
not much growth hormone receptor not
much growth hormone receptor
so they're perfectly intelligent they
live normal lives they just don't grow
very large
so i found this population fascinating
because
in my company united therapeutics we're
trying to create an unlimited supply of
transplantable organs
and one of the ways we do this is by
modifying the genome of the pig
and it's kind of like a fluke of nature
tim that the pig's organs their heart
their kidneys their
lungs are very much the same size and
functionality as human
kidneys hearts and lungs the only
problem
is that if you leave a pig on the zone
they'll actually grow extremely large
and when these first transplants were
done
they had to euthanize the animal
recipients of the transplants
because the organs from the pig had
grown too large
so what we did is we took a page from
this population of of people in peru and
ecuador the
western medicine gives them a disease
name it's called
laryn's disease l-a-r-o-n
after this israeli scientist who
discovered what was going on here
so we said well why don't we modify a
growth hormone receptor knockout
just like the laryn's population has
into these pigs so when we transplant
the kidneys of these pigs
into people the kidneys won't keep
growing and growing
as an a normal pig can be you know many
hundreds of pounds
instead the the kidney will just stop
growing at the same size
as when we transplanted it and that's
working out really well
let's talk more about organ
manufacturing so
what are some of the other precursors
or requirements for having a
sufficient supply of organs to meet
whatever demands there are
in the us or in the world today
so the the demands whether it's in the
u.s or outside the us
are are huge and are way way
in excess of the supply i would say that
one of the
greatest unmet medical needs today
is an adequate supply of transplantable
organs
now it's it's a beautiful thing that you
know before
people like tom starzel questioned
authority
and said it was possible to do an organ
transplant
in our parents teenage years and adult
years that would have just been like
crazy stuff like you take an organ from
a dead person you put it in a live
person who has a bad organ and the
person comes back to health
i mean that that's about as crazy as it
gets but they did it
you know they did it and now standing on
their shoulders
we have hundreds of thousands of people
clamoring for these organs
yet each year there are only about 30
000 kidneys available for transplant
only around 3 000 hearts only around 2
000 lungs
and so the gap between the need for
these organs and the supply
is is humongous are you still
or i should say united therapeutics
currently trying to manipulate the vagus
nerve
is that in in process
yes that isn't in process and it's a
it's a fascinating area
tim we are very fortunate to work with
the father of
bioelectronic medicine dr uh kevin tracy
he's the
chief medical officer at the northwell
medical complex up in the new york area
and by the way that reminds me speaking
of how can
lay people get access to scientific
knowledge easily
subscribe to scientific american i'm
sorry to put an advertisement in here
scientifically but um i find scientific
american and national geographic two of
like you know the greatest ways for
lay people which i do consider myself a
lay person
to learn about all different types of
signs that they might not know anything
about so one day i got my scientific
american
in the mail and on the cover it was
using electronics to cure diseases
well here i am like my whole career has
just been like electronic engineering
building satellites and now
because of my daughter i'm like in this
medical field
so i'm like so excited it was one of
those lightning bolts to the soul
now i have a chance to bring my male and
female side together
to bring my satellite and my biology
side together and merge them
so i got very excited and i had a chance
to
meet and now work with and support the
work of
dr tracy and he taught me a very simple
sentence tim which i've subsequently
found to be absolutely true in all the
research i've read
it is that the nervous system touches
every single cell in your body
the nervous system touches every single
cell
in our body the largest nerve in the
body
there's one nerve that is way way larger
than
all the rest of them it's the vagus
nerve it starts in our mind
it wraps around our heart our lungs our
gut
it's it's an immense nerve and
by stimulating this vagus nerve
it's possible to have positive
therapeutic effects in the body
by a fluke of nature a positive fluke
the vagus nerve
comes out to the skin in two and only
two places
around the left and right ears you know
there are like a couple of different
ridges in your earlobe
or your ear i guess you would say it and
the one of them
called the simba conkey is the place
where the vagus nerve
comes out and if you electrically
stimulate
the symbiconkey on either the left or
the right here
it's been proven now again lots of
published
literature to have positive therapeutic
effects on the body
what are some of those positive
therapeutic effects
sure so one which has been um
documented quite extensively is the
ability to
control crohn's disease and irritable
bowel syndrome which are two
gastrointestinal problems as well
as very high priced and and i would say
tinged with some potential side effect
biologic medicines that are approved by
the fda
to treat crohn's disease and irritable
bowel syndrome
another illness that has been shown to
mediate against
is rheumatoid arthritis and the the
common
factor here is that we have two types of
nervous systems we have a fight or
flight nervous system
which is the sympathetic nervous system
and we have a rest and digest nervous
system
which is called the parasympathetic
nervous system
when diseases occur it's because one of
those two nervous systems
the sympathetic one the fight-or-flight
takes more of a dominant position in the
body and causes a state of
inflammation or over-activation and by
stimulating the vagus nerve
you can ramp up the power of the
parasympathetic nervous system
and calm down this kind of overstressed
state
that leads to an irritable bowel
syndrome or to on the inflammation of
arthritis
this is in the course of doing all the
reading for this conversation
one of those things that really woke me
up
and made me pay attention for a bunch of
reasons one is relevance to my current
life because i've been working with
a doctor for about 10 weeks doing heart
rate variability training
and there are some researchers with
claims i want to say out of rutgers and
elsewhere
that certain types of hrv training
affect vagal tone and
via affecting that vehicle tone have a
host of cascading
uh therapeutic benefits whether or not
that that holds up to scrutiny or not i
don't know but the the second
and i'm embarrassed to even give voice
to this
so hopefully this won't just destroy any
tiny shred of
credibility that i might have as i
mentioned it but
why i lived in china for a period of
time in college went to universities
there
in beijing as uh effectively an exchange
student but it was a one-way exchange i
don't think we had any students
in return from china and
the ears are very much utilized
in the world of acupuncture and i'm
curious to know if you
think that whether by trial and error or
otherwise
it's possible that acupuncture
stumbled upon the effects without
knowing
the mechanism of
stimulating or affecting the ears
to then in turn affect the vagus nerve i
know it's
it's quite a stretch but when i first
read about this access via the ears
that is one thing that jumped to mind
because i always kind of pooh-poohed and
if i'm being honest ridiculed the idea
of
using the ears to access these deep
inner points but
here we are so i don't know if you have
any thoughts
tim your first your your credibility is
immense so
don you would have to you would have to
actually say something crazy to denton
or what you said is the
opposite of crazy what you said is
extremely insightful and prescient
so as convinced as i was that putting a
satellite
in geostationary orbit would enable
people across the planet to receive
radio signals
as convinced as i was that we could have
a molecule that would halt the
progression of my daughter and other
people's disease
that's exactly how convinced i am that
the
acupuncturists of traditional chinese
medicine
did in fact come upon the nerve patterns
that are accessible
from the earlobe and one of the first
things that dr tracy
showed me was a very
medically accurate from a chinese
traditional medicine practitioner
map of the earlobe in terms of exactly
where
you put i'm i'm sorry i don't know what
the official name is of the
of the pins or needles that they put in
your earlobe
and how they map to different parts of
the body and then he
showed me on an anatomy map how that
traces
the lines of the vagus nerve that's why
wow yeah it's it is totally true
and why really would it not be true i
mean you know
thousands of years of chinese
civilization
they have had a chance to do so much
trial and error
and they were a literate civilization
for so long so that
results that trial and error could be
passed on and passed on
so i i do think it's entirely rational
that they would have figured this out
and what i'm hoping for now and what i'm
trying to support
is there is an opportunity
to what i would what i call in my own
words crack
the human neurom so what that means is
that there
are a unique pattern
of amplitudes and signal
lengths and signal voltages that will
activate
some different part of the vagus nerve
than others and each of these different
voltages and wavelengths will correlate
to a different part of the human body
we don't know what those are right now
we are just kind of
in a way i would say we're more dumber
than than the acupuncturist
because almost all of the work that the
fda has allowed to go forward on vagal
nerve stimulation
they all use the same pulse width the
same pulse power and it works so that's
great
you know but i think it could work even
better if we
decoded the the human neuron
and i believe in the future people will
be able to put on a pair of like beat
headsets
and uh those beat headsets will have
gel-less
uh meaning like you don't need like the
ekg kind of gel
gel-less electrodes will rest across
your
symbiconkey and your traeger in the
different parts of your earlobe
and will provide you a stimulation that
matches the particular ailment that you
have
eliminate the ailment without taking any
pills without paying any money to
anybody
this is an area i want to keep digging
in because
it's rare well it's pretty much
non-existent that i have the opportunity
to speak
with someone with so much electrical
engineering background
about the possible applications or
implications of technology like this
i'd love to just throw out another group
of devices to see if you have any
opinions on them one way or the other
but potential applications
of let's just say tdcs
or tms or transcranial
direct current stimulation or other
means of
stimulating the brain typically using
some type of conducive gel
but not always in the case of a tms
paddle have you looked at these
technologies
or done any reading in the literature
related to them a little bit i'm
aware of a friend of mine has a company
that
obtained an fda approval for treating
a particular form of brain cancer with
this type of technology
so there's there's a very solid
scientific benefit
that's been documented after many years
of working through the fda
i will i have a world of respect for the
rigor
that they put into any decision to
approve something so when they approved
it
it meant that it was scientifically
proven to work
something that is quite different from
that but at the same time
related to it tim is on the
last day of 2019
which was like the last day of the
decade
it turned out to be a weekday i forget
if it was a tuesday or whatever
but the u.s patent office only issues
patents on one day of a week
and it was like the one day of the week
that they issue them on
whether it's tuesday or whatever and it
was a patent
that that i received for a device that i
call a
alzheimer's cognitive enabler and this
device
is worn over the cranium as you
mentioned
and it senses nerve impulses
inside the brain it is connected to
a computer with a visual recognition and
a speech comprehension system so that
if a patient with alzheimer's is not
able to adequately
communicate and appear to recognize the
people who are coming into their room
the computer vision recognition system
and
sound recognition system will talk on
behalf
of the alzheimer's patient say you know
hello son
thank you for for coming to see me and
it is actually being triggered by
recognitions that are deep in the
alzheimer's
patient's mind so that more people will
come to visit the patient
the patient's stress levels um may be
lower
so i believe this kind of bridging of
electronics and the mind is
is really right around the corner what
inspired
putting the work into
that research and filing that patent i
think part of it was
was seeing my mother-in-law suffer
pretty badly from somewhere on the
spectrum between dementia and
alzheimer's was never really completely
clear where she was
at that and um she would
she would recognize us coming in but she
couldn't communicate
and it would have meant a lot to
everybody if she would be able to
communicate
my own mother is is more or less at that
point right now as well
secondly the work on the bena48 computer
showed me that it was really possible
for people to
strike up meaningful relationships with
the digital version of bina the being a
48 robot
and so it was just like you know a very
short step from
instead of putting all of bina's
or even a good portion of her memories
and her personality into this computer
why not actually have the computer's
interaction capability input output
capability
triggered by something like a neurosky
type of
eeg brain interface and the last piece
of it was i was
i was given a um a christmas present by
a friend of mine
which was one of these neural sky
headsets that lets you kind of like play
a game just with your thoughts
by controlling your eeg signals so
that's a consumer product anybody can
buy
and it really works well you know this
conversation brings back a lot of
memories for me because i have
alzheimer's disease is very prevalent on
both sides of my family and
observed both sets of my grandparents
deteriorate
to the point where at least some of them
couldn't recognize immediate family
members
and was recently re-watching segments of
a documentary i saw
called alive inside and the subtitle is
a story of music and memory
and what struck me most about
this documentary is that not that they
could play
music from someone's youth to them
through headsets and watch them come
alive in some
really spectacular ways both physically
in terms of kinesiology moving around
but also psychologically
the most impressive part to me is that
they would play music for say a handful
of minutes
five to ten minutes from someone's youth
and then
turn off the music and that person could
have a
perfectly coherent reasonably fast speed
conversation
whereas prior to the administration of
the music they were
from the outside catatonic basically
and it makes me wonder what music
is doing i'm sure there are people who
study this and probably have
a better mechanistic explanation and how
it could be incorporated
into therapies intended to counter
dementia or advanced alzheimer's disease
things of this type
tim you see like just in this
conversation we are uncovering like so
many
you know vast new oceans of opportunity
for people to learn and study about
music to me music is the foundational
human technology because the first thing
that we ever could become aware of
would be the beat of our mother's hearts
while we were still
in utero and that beat that's a rhythm
okay and after we're born you know
people may have better or worse rhythm
but there's nobody
that cannot detect the sound of a beat
and move to it
and then all the different types of
melodies and chords
that build upon rhythm it's just fancier
and fancier forms of music so
i i believe that there's tremendous
therapeutic properties to music
it's just been scratched not even
scratch has been kind of like
blown on like
and it's it's there for like all the
thousands of young people today
who have come up grown up with more
music than ever before
to begin to apply this great human
cultural technology of music to the
biggest mystery in the entire universe
which is the human mind
i want to come back to the mind or more
more
accurately consciousness in a moment
but first this will seem like a left
turn and it is
i was reading a piece in the washington
post that
covered quite quite a lot of your life
and there was
a segment on love night i don't know if
that's enough of a prompt
but can you tell us what love night is
so when dina my partner and i got
married we each had
one child from a previous marriage that
each of us had custody of and
then we had two children together and we
were
kind of trying to build a blended family
that would feel like nobody was a
stepmom or a step dad that everybody was
just
like in one family and in fact we cross
adopted each other's kids from
our previous marriages so i was taking
the kids to
music classes all of the kids were in
the
yamaha music program where they learned
piano and violin instruments like that
and we would practice songs and i was
brought up jewish
where every friday night was something
that was special it was the sabbath
and the family sat down together and had
dinner
and said a couple of prayers so bina and
i
tried to think how can we like merge all
these things together the jewish
tradition
the need to create a blended family the
music that we were all enjoying from
watching the kids learn to play piano
and violin
and we decided to every friday night
have a special family ceremony which we
would call
love night and we sang a song which the
melody was actually
based on one of the kids songs that they
had learned in the
yamaha music program the words were
you know very simple and affirming
and at love night the core of love night
was that each person around the table
would have an opportunity to say what
love meant to them
during the past week during the week
from the previous friday to this friday
what does love mean to you and you know
bina and i
as the adults we would say something
either sophisticated
or or simple like i love being i love
martine i love the kids
the kids started off just saying like
what love means to me is like
our dogs or our you know very basic
things
but as they grew older they came into
more and more sophisticated definitions
and
expressions of love until you know
after a couple of decades of this i have
heard
all of them there all of us have heard
thousands of different things
that love can mean to a person now i'd
like to fast forward and
sorry to be in a little riff here but i
want to fast forward to the current
covet pandemic
our kids are all adults now they've
flown the coop they have their own kids
and suddenly we are in a situation
where we can't all gather together in
any one house for
love night you don't want to travel you
don't want to like endanger people
so on and so forth so we decided to
continue the love night tradition but on
zoom
or to be fair google meet so every
friday night
from my son who's a uh a captain in the
army
in iraq to his wife who's on a base in
el paso to my other son with
four grandchildren in florida to my
daughter in brooklyn and her kid
and her husband and vina and i we all
get together on zoom
plus friends of all of ours the kids
were not embarrassed by love night in
fact they wanted to share it with their
friends and their friends were saying
like whoa
this is crazy this is beautiful and so
we get together every friday night
we sing our love night song and now
there's about 20 of us
you know we go around virtually what
love meant to us during that
previous week and i would say love night
is one of the most beautiful parts of my
life
ah i am so glad that i asked that
question
and love knight could you give a few
more examples
of possible answers just to give
people a flavor
for how people might answer this
question
because i for instance would love to try
this with my girlfriend with
some of our friends family etc but i
would be
nervous as the orchestrator that i might
get that question and not
have the ability to kick things off
effectively
so every morning uh bean and my partner
goes out for takes our two dogs out for
a walk
with one of her best friends who lives a
few houses away
and that best friend now joins our love
nights
and last friday she said what love means
to me
is every morning going out for a walk
with bina and the dogs
last week our youngest grandson saturn
he's you know was born in 2010 so he's
10 years old
he said what love means to me
is this and he pulled a piece of paper
he said i got a 95 on my math test
and he was just so proud of himself and
and
and shared it with us so those are
typical examples of um
i think i last time said what love means
to me
is sitting down at the piano and playing
different songs from memory
so to use this as a uh skipping
uh i was gonna say a skipping stone but
i think i'm getting my metaphors mixed
up i see a launch launchpad
a lilypad pick your pick your choice
to consciousness do you think
that we will be able to as i've heard
you put it once recapitulate
uh or or recreate consciousness
synthetically and
does that mean we'll have machines that
can love for instance in the not too
distant future what what
what would it mean to have created
consciousness
sure i i do believe it's possible and a
great book that i would recommend that
goes into this subject in beautiful
detail
is called the emotion machine by marvin
minsky
and marvin minsky is often thought of as
the father of artificial intelligence
he was a professor at mit for a great
many years
so in the emotion machine book he really
describes
exactly how you would go about creating
a computer and the type of software
that it would take in order for the
machine
to feel what we feel when we say
that we love somebody and i i think it's
likely to occur
tim because it's hard for me to think of
any aspect of uh life
that cannot be replicated if one had
sufficiently advanced technology
one of my favorite sayings from another
role model
arthur c clarke is that you know magic
is
indistinguishable from sufficiently
advanced technology so
i think just like we have been able to
create
an artificial hip artificial knees
artificial hearts i'm in my own company
we are building lungs and kidneys
people are creating artificial nerves
people like elon musk has formed a whole
company neurolink
where he's working on downloading a
human a whole human brain
i have little doubt that humans will end
up being able to
replicate a human mind now whether or
not the
rest of society accepts it as a human
mind or not
i think is going to be a long pitch
battle and that's what
is the subject of my book virtually
human
that whole book is talks about how and
when will society
accept digital consciousness as being as
conscious as a human but even if that
digital consciousness
is not yet at human level what happens
when it's at say
primate level or at canine level
or even at a rodent level if you can get
to any of these levels you could kind of
see how it's the same old human effort
of keep making incremental improvements
that would eventually get you to the
human level where
i i think that the individual alive
today that has the best
understanding of this topic is a guy at
google named ray kurzweil
he's a director of engineering at google
and what i love about ray is he never
tires of pointing out that this digital
human consciousness it's
human you know consciousness is a
is a human consciousness is a human
phenomena
so when we create a digital analog
or doppelganger or cymokra whatever you
want to call it
when we create a her that her is human
it's not us versus them it's
one it's we will have been able to move
our mind
into a digital substrate just like if
our knees give out
you move it to a mechanical substrate or
if an organ gives out you transplant it
with another organ
where would you if you had to kind of
price's right style
put a timeline on this when do you think
we'll have
rodent or canine level consciousness
plus intelligence yeah it's pretty hard
to say tim because one thing i am not
is i'm not a soo sayer i'm not a prophet
i'm not a
visionary any of those things i'm i'm
just a humble technologist and
all the projects i work on they have
five-year time horizons because i have
difficulty really seeing beyond five
years so every technology i'm working on
it's like i want to get this thing
done and out to the public within five
years
also i am totally a believer
in this uh adage that futurists
usually over promise in the near term
and under promise in the long term so
what that would mean in this context
is you will hear a lot of futurists
saying
oh we'll have digital rats or digital
dogs or digital people
in 10 20 or 30 years they have probably
over promised in the near term what they
have under promise in the long term is
in not 10 20 30 years but in say
80 90 or 100 years there won't be just
digital rats digital dogs and digital
people
but most people will be digital
exciting and i suppose for some people
very terrifying
at the same time what are some of the
most
important ethical questions or
considerations related to technology
as we move into future decades
in your mind yes in in my mind the
biggest problem
with technology is that people only
think about the rights to
implement the technology and they don't
think about
the obligations they have as somebody
creating a technology
and by what i mean by that is you know
there was this great philosopher of the
20th century
isaac berlin i believe he was german
and he had a real simple message
his message was that for every right
there is an obligation it's again it's a
very alan watson
sorry to keep coming back to alan watts
but it's a very
alem watson point of view that a right
only means something in the context of
its obligation
so for example if i have a right to be a
parent
which we think everybody you know has a
right to be a parent
you only have that right to be a parent
so long as you comply with your
obligation
to be at least not a horrible parent if
you're
a horrible parent you will have your
children taken away from you and you'll
no longer in that sense
be a parent so with regard to technology
i think there is a point of view that
anybody who can create a technology has
a right to make that technology
but i dispute the ethics of that
perspective
i think that um every right to make a
technology
is coupled to an obligation to have the
consent
of anybody who would be adversely
affected by that technology
so for example my right to build an
atomic power plant or a nuclear power
plant someplace
i don't just have that right that right
is coupled to an
obligation that i have to have the
consent
of all the surrounding communities of
people
who could be adversely affected by the
implementation of that technology
and it comes into this uh domain of of
in my own field
say the transplantation of genetically
modified pig organs
into people for me to have a right to do
that technology
i have to have the consent of the larger
community
that that's a safe thing to do in a
democratic country
that consent is issued on behalf of the
country by the
government and in the field of health
it's issued by the fda
so before the fda permits us to
transplant these genetically modified
pig organs
into people they want us to demonstrate
to them that there is no risk
not a small risk but no risk of any kind
of
animal virus seeping into the human
population
as a result of these animal transplants
so in summary
i believe like an amazing field for the
future
a field that will probably in the future
have almost as many people with this
career as
our web designers today is the field of
techno ethics
everybody who wants to create a
technology will need to
wrap that technology in an ethical
envelope of consent if we look at
you know science over well we could look
at it over the last few thousand years
but let's just say last
few hundred years you mentioned earlier
that as i think you were discussing the
structure of scientific revolutions how
these breakthroughs these massive
scientific
leaps forward seemed like complete
madness at the time
to the vast majority and we don't have
to go that far
back to find say surgery without
or with minimal use of anesthetics on
newborns and infants i mean this is not
the dark ages this is you know less than
100 years ago you see some some really
appalling things that were
taken as best practices or common
practice
and one of my friends who's an
outstanding doctor
likes to repeat this i suppose adage
that you hear among good doctors which
is 50
of what we know is wrong we just don't
know which 50 percent
and that seems to always be true so
if we flash forward 10 or 20 years and i
know you're not a profit or a soucer but
i'm curious or even
or it could be five years as a
technologist
what do you think are any of the things
we're doing now or believe
now that will be shown to be patently
absurd
or viewed as barbaric or crazy
or naive in the near future well
probably probably a lot of things
yeah since a lot of you know what we
look back in the past that seems to be
barbaric um building on top of your
example
of the tortuous procedures
put onto neonates people forget
that the founder of the american medical
association
the first doctor who was the who created
the american medical association
his name was dr gross and
he lived in philadelphia and he did not
believe
in a sepsis at all and so he would do
all of his procedures right in his
street clothes
infecting everybody and countless women
lost their lives because of having those
type of quote unquote doctors
helping with the delivery of the
children and ending up you know creating
a septic condition
in the mothers and one of the most
famous painters in american history
thomas aikens painted this picture of
the gross clinic
where dr gross was teaching all the
young doctors how to do a procedure and
you see
dirt in his shoes and scuffy hands
then he was followed the second
president of the american medical
association was a
dr agnew who was the student of gross
and he had read about the research of
lister
in england and became a believer that
even though we can't see these things
germs they're real and we need to
practice you know
strict uh septic procedures before we do
an operation
a few years later thomas aikens painted
the agnew clinic
and you see that the doctors and white
smocks and everybody is you know looking
super sterile and clean so these
type of revolutions can occur just like
one generation to the next it's not
something that takes
it takes a long time i think that um
you know looking at uh what's going on
today in our world
i think the fact that we burn our own
house
will look to be absolutely bonkers
people say well let me get this right
you've got like you know
a super thin atmosphere i mean you guys
saw that from space since the 60s at
least
this atmosphere around your planet is
super thin you have a
undeniable record of measurements of
of carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
going up year after year after year
and you continue to just spew without
limit
greenhouse gases into this atmosphere
despite the fact that you know
people are dying on the shorelines dying
of diseases
etc etc i i think they will think we are
as stupid as somebody
who would light a fire in the middle of
their house to try to keep warm
and not bother with the smoke that they
were choking on
yeah and then if i could add an addendum
to them
you could say well whenever did you guys
know that the earth receives
10 000 times the amount of solar energy
falls right on the earth
each day than it uses ten thousand times
the amount of energy
it flows and that's not to talk about
the wind
and that's not to talk about the waves
and that's not to talk about the nuclear
energy
i mean i think the people in the future
may think we were pretty stupid
to be so scared of nuclear energy
which has killed a few dozens of people
that we went ahead and just you know
stopped all the nuclear plants
and began pouring ungodly amounts of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
that will kill millions of people that
will seem ludicrous to them
i think this is uh and i won't keep you
too much longer but i think this
i would be remiss if i didn't ask you to
comment
on or describe your own
engineering projects with carbon
neutrality or zero emissions as
as an objective because this is not just
kind of idle
hand waving for you this is something
that you've taken a keen
engineering mind to and and i think that
was not mentioned in your bio even
though it's
yet another one of these uh examples
of your sort of extreme curiosity and
capability
that could you just describe what you've
done in that arena please
so this is another area that's that
gives me
immense enjoyment again another kind of
like lightning bolt to my soul
is to try to create infrastructure
buildings
and cars and planes and things that
have a zero carbon footprint and i
look at it as an intellectual challenge
when i've
read that people said well we cannot
have a
zero carbon footprint society until
2050 that's what the authorities say
you know already tim i'm going to say
why why not
why not why not i'm going to question
that authority
so about three years ago we undertook
to build a new headquarters for a
company in silver spring maryland that
would have a zero carbon footprint
not in the best climate maryland it's
got its
good seasons and it's bad seasons right
in the middle of a city silver spring
maryland is a built up
suburb of washington dc and for the
manufacture of medicines and stuff which
is a
somewhat of an energy intensive activity
so we built um a 150 000 square foot
zero carbon footprint building which
turned out to be the largest zero carbon
footprint building in the entire world
and we inaugurated it a couple years ago
it turns out we produce
more energy than we use each year now
two years running we did this by just
thinking carefully about energy and
and how to manage it so for example we
have
underneath the building 50 wells
each of which go down 500 feet and they
exchange
heat from the building with the coolness
of the earth
in the summer bring the coolness back up
and in the winter
they exchange coolness of the building
with the steady temperature of the earth
in the winter to keep the building warm
the sides of the building
are clouded with solar panels the entire
building has a brain
that automatically opens the windows and
closes the windows to allow
natural ventilation it's a role model
for many other buildings and lots of
designers and engineers have come over
there
another example is in the delivery of
our organs when
we right now we refurbish organs lungs
in particular
that a decedent has donated
or the decedent's family has agreed to
the donation
but when the transplant surgeons look at
that lung they say it's too much
full of fluid and mucus we can't use it
throw it away
so what united therapeutics says is give
us your lonely unwanted unloved lungs
fly them to silver spring maryland we
will refurbish them
we'll show through a high-speed digital
network to the transplant surgeons all
across the country
that the organ is good as new through
this digital network
and bronchoscope and x-ray and all that
stuff
and then we fly the lungs back out to
them we've saved over 150 lives this way
tim
how do you refurbish a lung you
you first you have to remove it from the
dying body a dying body is a terrible
place to be
so we remove it from the decedent um we
cool it down
so we kind of give it a i won't say we
freeze it but we cool it down very
very low temperature we fly it to
maryland and we put it in a glass dome
and in this glass dome we have tubes we
have a kind of artificial blood
and air pumping so we've made a kind of
isolated artificial body just for that
lung
and we have expert technicians who work
um
these sorry don't know the exact name of
the equipment but it sucks out
mucus and and the they operate on the
lungs
like it was a person but it's just an
isolated pair of lungs
and the transplant doctors who could be
in texas or florida wherever
they tell us through the the digital
screen and the
voice um put the bronchoscope down the
left side or
down the right side to go further give
me heck they they see this and they know
what they want
so our technicians know how to do this
and within four hours
in almost two-thirds of the time we were
able to take what was a non-compliant
dead piece of tissue and turn it into a
nicely breathing lung
it's so beautiful to watch tim the lungs
go in and out
like a butterfly's wings going up and
down in fact you could see a video of it
on that washington post article you were
mentioning
and then we cool the lungs back down and
we fly
it to the transplant surgeon and um 100
percent of the time that they have
accepted these lungs
they have had successful lung
transplants with like i mentioned over
150 people walking out of the hospital
but i mentioned this because this is a
lot of flying around
flying here flying there you know
helicopters going back and forth planes
and if i'm going to make an unlimited
supply of organs
and you remember all those numbers we
talked about at the beginning of the
call the hundreds of thousands of people
who needs these organs
that is going to be a humongous carbon
footprint
we could have said to ourselves well
we're doing such a good thing we're
saving all these lives we could be
permitted to
foul our atmosphere because it's
balanced by the good things we're doing
but instead we like to ask ourselves
like the challenging question
how can we do like the good thing and
the right thing
at the same time how can we manufacture
all these lungs
and deliver them with a zero carbon
footprint
and the solution came from the
technology of electric helicopters
which are powered by renewable energy
that can fly these
organs from one place to the other
without adding any
carbon footprint at all and i will be a
little bit of a soothsayer here
i am absolutely convinced that in this
decade the 2020s
we will be delivering manufactured
organs by electric helicopter
i love it i have i will say one i may
cheat and sneak in
one or two more but uh a question
well likewise this is just endlessly
endlessly interesting so many so many
different pathways into the labyrinth
but i need to make sure i suppose since
my job is supposedly interviewer that i
can find my way back out
uh i have read that alan waltz will show
you the way
alan watts will show you the way he does
have a most
seductive and hypnotic voice for those
who haven't heard i recommend
i i've read that a favorite saying of
yours is
quote identify the corridors of
indifference and run like hell down them
end quote can you please speak to that
or explain what that means for you yes
so identify the corridors of
indifference and run like hell
down them means to try to find
a i'll put it in business terms a market
area
that is ignored a unmet
need but it doesn't really have to just
apply to medicine it can apply to any
area of life
and the way i would phrase it on tim in
just like
you know a very natural almost
folklorish way
is that it's better to be a big fish in
a small pond
than a small fish in a big pond in a
business school back at ucla we one
person we studied a lot
was the experience of general electric
under jack welch and he had an adage
which from a business sense was i think
very very smart
he said if you can't be number one or
number two in the market
don't even try because you will have to
spend an amount of money
equal to the revenues of the number one
or a number two in that market
to become the number one or number two
in the market if you're not the number
one or number two
you will always struggle to be
profitable but if you
are the number one or number two your
profitability is assured
so what that means translated to all of
our activities
is if there's an area like for example
a number of people have said you know we
should get involved we when i say we my
company knight therapeutics
should get involved in creating a
vaccine for
covid and to me well you know it's not a
corridor of indifference
there are dozens of companies working on
a vaccine for kovid
so that's not what we would want to do
it's very unlikely we'd ever be
successful on that
somebody else said well how about these
people the covid
long haulers the people who have
survived from a very difficult course of
covid
and they've got chronic lung problems
that are bothering them months and
likely years after the effect i said yes
that's a corridor of indifference nobody
is thinking about the long haulers
the people who now have you know chronic
lung problems because of the
havoc that covid wrapped in their lungs
let's develop some medicines for these
chronic long haulers makes a lot of
sense
and it makes a lot of sense and on a
related maybe a related note in some
respects
uh and this is this is a question it
doesn't always work so i'll take the
blame
if it doesn't but if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a a
message a quote a word an image
a question anything out to billions of
people let's just assume they all speak
english for the
sake of of argument what might you put
on that billboard
i think apple computer and steve jobs
got there before me
think different think different why is
that important
because the solutions you know albert
einstein said you can't solve a problem
on the same level
that it was created you have to solve it
on a
different level if we all think the
exact same way
we will never get out of the ruts that
we're in
the only way to get out of the problems
that we face
is to think differently to go down the
corridor of
indifference to question authority
to be diverse thinking different
is the pathway to solving problems that
exist today
you know looking back at everything
we've talked about
and looking at all the copious pages of
notes for prep in front of me it strikes
me that
you've forged many paths for yourself
and helped others to do the same by by
thinking different
but also thinking brightly coming back
to alan watts
yet again right the the yin and the
young and seeing
the positive looking for the positive in
different circumstances different
situations do you have any advice or
recommendations for people who struggle
to do that who are maybe mired in a
sense of
hopelessness might be too too strong a
word but those who tend to see the
glass as half full and perhaps as a
result of that
tend to see half the spectrum of options
or solutions
it's a really difficult question to
answer tim because
everybody's situation is so unique and
so different
and i do not doubt that for
many many people it is just a bad life
whether it started that way or ended up
the way and it's almost
impossible to see a way out the
perspective that i take
is that i try to stay in touch with my
ancestors
i think about the great grandmothers
who had to you know bear children in the
worst of possible circumstances i think
about
you know all of the like my partner
bina's
great grandmothers who were picking
cotton
as slaves and had to work all day
being bitten up by bugs burning in the
sun feet
deep in mud and then bear a child at the
last moment
so whether it's like you know my
great-grandparents from eastern europe
or hers from
the african diaspora they had nothing to
look forward to
other than just the hope that they were
going to have some children
and that maybe those children might have
a little bit of a better life than they
did
and if not their children their
children's children
so their only purpose in life their only
hope in life their only joy
in life was to make a generation
and that maybe that generation would be
better now here we are
in in america or really most any other
country in the world
we're at a point now where like eight
out of 10 people
have a smartphone with access to all the
world's knowledge and information
with access to countless amounts of
music and
and training through youtube there are
many people in the world still in dire
circumstances
but the vast majority of people are
doing better than people have ever done
before in history
so i say to myself and i would ask you
know
somebody else looking through the world
darkly right now looking at the
glass half full i would say how much
worse
it must have been in the past what do i
owe
to my grandparents and
great-grandparents and
great-great-grandparents
who suffered and toiled who barely
managed to survive to produce another
generation
what do i owe to them i owe to them to
make the absolute most
possible out of my life and that's what
i'm going to do
hot damn martian i'm ready to get out
there and get amongst it i
have so enjoyed this conversation
there are 79 more hours we could do just
in
round one i won't subject you to that
and
i'm so grateful that you were willing to
make the time to have this conversation
thank you so much my pleasure being with
you tim
and is there anything else you would
like to
to say to suggest or ask of those
listening before we
bring this to a close two of my best
friends and people who
i think are the smartest most creative
most
happy loving people i know paul mann and
d.a wallach both said to me that uh your
podcast is the best
and martine if if tim ferriss invites
you on your on this podcast you have to
go on it so
thank you d.a and thank you paul
thanks to them also from me i have for
many months my whole team knows this
been hoping
to have you on i had high hopes coming
into it
uh you you exceeded all of those high
hopes
which seems to be a pattern for you
and i'm just very grateful and happy
that we had a chance
to connect so so thank you again and for
everyone listening you can find martine
on instagram
transbinary twitter at sky biome we will
link to everything
in the show notes that
have mentioned in this conversation the
books and everything
you can imagine that we discussed will
be available in the show notes
tim dot blog forward slash podcast and
until next time
be kind practice love night think
different
think brightly and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
four hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by freshbooks
thousands of listeners and a lot of the
contractors i use
and my readers use freshbooks if you've
been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into
a full-time small business or big
business for that matter
you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and
that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience who can help
you with support how do you manage the
billing and all of that
but still focus on the primary work of
your business and on growing your
business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign-up flows
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time financial assistant with you
every step of the way
you can create customize and send
branded and professional looking
invoices
in about 30 seconds you get paid up to
twice as fast
with fees as low as one percent using
ach payments on freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast
and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have
your questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now
but your ability to build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of
doesn't have to be one of those things
business owners all over the world rate
freshbooks as the easiest accounting
software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.comtim to check
it out and try it for free for 30 days
one more time
freshbooks.com tim
this episode is brought to you by
headspace life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a one
and done band-aid
quick is fine but we need stuff that is
durable and that's where headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2000 plus apps
for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation headspace can really help you
feel better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos
meditation for you need some help
falling asleep headspace has wind down
sessions their members swear by and for
parents headspace even has morning
meditations you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
lose focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder
andy it's put a [ __ ] could be putty comb
i'm not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable
and i did a three-minute meditation
something like that it's easy
it's fundamental and it always puts me
in a better
space so i'm going through the basics
even though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you on your
schedule anytime
anywhere we all want to feel happier we
all want more peace
and headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com
tim that's headspace.com tim for a free
one month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break a glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today